I'm just fascinated by people thinking
there's some secret passive potion that
you're gonna make a million bucks a year
doing dick you got your prospective
happy happy
[Music]
the only way you're gonna work 15 hours
a day for 25 years is cuz it's your
hobby you don't do anything that much
and you unless you [ __ ] love it right
like to me that's why I was I always
talk about being an entrepreneur before
it was cool it's cuz it's what I loved
it's it's like if you were to listen to
music for if you love music and I said
you literally for a living can listen to
music for 15 hours a day and do
extremely well I wouldn't sign up for
that I don't want to listen to music 15
hours a day but I'm sure a lot of people
would or play tennis or whatever like
and I think that the people that will we
succeed in the long term have found that
thing that thing that they genuinely
like would do like I I wouldn't I will
never retire it just will never happen I
just know it already today
I may get super old and like I might not
be able to slip around but like I'll go
stand in a flea market and sell some
[ __ ] like to me it's the thing I've you
know it's really been interesting going
through this journey you know even for a
lot of you it's just interesting to
analyze yourself as you evolve as you
get older as a six to twelve year old
red unlimited freedom to play outside in
the 80s in New Jersey more than half the
time I chose to wash somebody's car
right
shovel somebody's snow so this is like
deeply ingrained and I think I see it I
see it in architecture I see it in
teaching I see it in public service I
see an apparent thing like if you can
just find your thing now for me my thing
also creates financial ramp you know for
some people if your dream is to teach
you know like if you want to teach in a
public school you're not gonna make a
million dollars a year so I think right
now my fear and even like this whole
project is I'm trying to talk a lot more
about self awareness not just
entrepreneurship because I think people
are getting caught up because there's
just no way to be sustainable the reason
everybody's I get almost 10,000
communications a week about how do I fix
my laziness and my
sir is and my answer is do something you
like right you're lazy because you're
doing it for the money and you don't
like it you just think it's gonna make
you money and so people are real estate
agents because their neighbors making
money and people are social media
experts because they read something
about me or they're gonna be a crypto
currency trader or augmented reality
this and everyone's gonna be on VR and
the next thing and the next thing and
the next thing in there and this is why
so many people lose they chase cash and
to your point like hard work is part of
the equation like it's it's just part of
the equation because somebody's gonna
outwork you people like Gary me I get a
I don't know if you guys saw this I was
flying here today says I got kind of
caught up on work I'm like [ __ ] it let
me just answer questions so I did an
Instagram post today ask me questions
start answering people like yo Gary Vee
what do I do when my market gets really
competitive and everybody wants to do
the same [ __ ] I'm like you have to be
better than everyone right like like
it's so funny
like there's a lot of sneaker stores
like you know like you just have to be
better and so like I'm just fascinated
by people thinking there's some secret
passive potion that you're gonna make a
million bucks a year doing dick doesn't
exist so you better figure out what you
like because I was so bad at school
because by 9:30 I looked at the [ __ ]
clock until I got out of it at 3:00
because I hated it and so because I
lived my childhood in hating something
and not succeeding out of the hatred of
it the fact that 90% of people careers
are the way I did school and those are
longer and take up a lot more of your
life that's devastating to me and we
have to change that conversation
John on our dairy book and how I
recommend people have what we're dr.
days doing whatever it is whether or not
for me one of the conversations that I
wanted to create clarity over the last
four years is sleep right I answered
that today somebody's like how much do
you know a lot of people asked how much
do you sleep and my answer six seven or
eight hours and it [ __ ] with people
right because they think I'm sleeping
like an hour and my point there is
sleeps important like I don't know like
who thinks they're gonna survive without
sleep sleeps important what's important
for what I'm about is what you're doing
when you're awake I'm fascinated by
people who like say I hustle I sleep for
hours but then watch three hours of
YouTube videos a day right and so for me
as you know and what you're referring to
as somebody who interacts with me is you
know Tyler's sending you emails like can
you do 11:30 p.m. to 12:30 p.m.
I'm every minute I have is programmed
[Music]
yeah no look I mean the amount of five
and seven and 10 and 13 like I basically
Tyler what I see your face what do you
think it's eight the eight o'clock until
11 p.m. is pretty much programmed to the
minute with zero slots for anything but
the next meeting but I'm working out
right but like for like work eight to 11
with zero lunch zero downtime like if I
go take a piss I'm cutting into some
meeting
now but here's the thing here's the
thing that's matching my happiness and
ambition that is not for 99.9% of people
I time management needs to be predicated
on what makes you happy and what is
coming out of your mouth the biggest
thing I'm worried about is people are
talking big game but then their actions
don't match it so to me it's happiness
first and then eliminating hypocrisy and
that's how I think about it so for me
it's that because I love this game it's
what I would want to do and my ambitions
are great and I enjoy it I want to spend
9:00 p.m. to 10:00 p.m. on a meeting to
build what I'm building it's it's what I
love to do it's no different than being
in the studio or painting or you know
it's just what I love to do I probably
both you guys biggest fans and I what
continues I would argue that if you
really knew everything about me and you
read it all every action I ever did you
would look me in the face and ask me why
do you sabotage yourself in business and
financials environments and I would tell
you that deep down subconsciously I
loved it so much that I just wanted to
happen forever
and so for me making it is is a four you
know it just there is that's what that's
what blows me away about somebody was
like I just need to make a million bucks
and I'm gonna go to Jamaica right or or
like I I don't have that I don't have
that in my head I just want to play
forever and that's why I'm trying to get
people to understand the process because
I've it is very clear to me that people
that are in love with their craft and
process can win and that's why I'm
trying to change the conversation around
how much money you need to be happy
because it doesn't work like I just know
unbelievable amounts of data of how many
people have lots of money how many
people don't have lots of money by our
standards and how happy they
and it doesn't take a lot of money to be
you know to be alive in society it's
about what you spend it money on I mean
I I can't get over this I just really
wish people liked what they did and the
Internet makes where we got caught why
everybody in this room is caught is you
were parented by people that didn't have
the luxury of a mature Internet and so
there was no practicality around doing
what you love it's just not how the
world worked the Internet which
everybody here including myself and
including the man who was at the
forefront of it in a lot of ways with
what he did with the iPhone is grossly
underestimated him like like deeply
underestimated and so I just I just
really want people to do what they like
it will work they just have to eat [ __ ]
for a long time like you're like well
Gary I have debt or a there's something
cool to live the life that you want
isn't it a good idea to punt the next
six years
eat [ __ ] give up because the game's very
simple if you've got debt or have to put
a roof over your head or somebody else
then you work whatever job is paying you
that but I'm asking you what are you
doing from 6:00 p.m. to midnight and if
you have to go build slowly your
portfolio your Shopify store your
Instagram account your YouTube channel
your content like like wouldn't you be
pumped if I told you for the next four
years it's tough and you don't watch as
much Netflix and Sports and hanging out
but then you get to live happy for the
rest of your life everybody in theory
would sign up for that the reality is a
lot of people don't want to grind for
four years like people don't like pain
it's why most people don't have
six-packs
I mean that I mean that there's a lot of
people here who want to be a better
shape you just don't want to work out
you just don't want to eat well like I
lived it for the first 38 years of my
life and then I got into better shape I
still hate it I [ __ ] was pissed this
morning waking up at five fifty five to
work out but because I want it and so
I've gone through doing something that
didn't come natural
that I hate to this day four and a half
years later but I just want to live 15
years longer and so for me it's like if
you're if any person here is unhappy I
need to know every single minute you
spend on anything but your job because
I'll tell you taking those leisure hours
which you're using to escape your
unhappiness you're literally watching
Netflix or sports or video playing video
games or listening to music to escape
your reality that you're not happy about
I want you to take those hours and start
building something that gets you off
your issue and it might take seven years
but it's worth it you're gonna everybody
here is gonna live for [ __ ] 60 70
more years people got tricked 54 is
young 54 is young and so people have
terrible ability to put time in
perspective which is why their behaviors
are so broken
[Applause]
I was
pretty sexy out there what is the
importance of investing in the people
and how do you inspire people who are
looking to accomplish their dreams and
how do you keep them going trying to
accomplish your vision in your dream to
me it's one-on-one marketing what you
know what Tyler cares about today is
different than what he cared about 24
months ago
d-roc cares if Colin worked for me and
because we had a real relationship I
helped put him on to the job he has
today and that's why he's sitting here
supporting me today so even when they're
out of the system it's one big system
karma is practical like doing the right
thing is always the right thing that is
actually how humans work it's why we're
still here humans are inherently
phenomenal this is what's so [ __ ] me
up about our culture right now we're
spending so much time on the negative
rightfully so there's so much political
banter there's so many people that are
trying to get their fair shake there's
so much going on I don't need to go
there but what it's done in the micro is
makes everybody look at the negative
instead of realizing this is the best
moment to be alive for anybody here who
on skin tone or race or gender feels
suppressed talk to your grandmother ask
him if it's better in 2018 than 1974
like people are confused and so like we
have a long way to go everywhere globe
but we lack we lack looking at the truth
and we lack optimism because most people
are so scared to get tricked they'd
rather be cynical I love when people
like yo gary vee but but you but I keep
it real I'm like you know you keep it
real negative you keep it real cynical
you don't keep it real optimism is a
strategy I really believe that like I
believe that life is completely a
perspective and like to me I'm solution
oriented every day every day my inbox is
filled my texts are filled with [ __ ]
that cripples people and for me it's
like I signed up for this if I want it
like everything's got a cost
most people want all these great things
they're just not willing to pay the
piper the emotional Piper that's the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] sucks everybody wants
to be an Instagram celebrity but nobody
wants anybody to leave a comment that
they're ugly so everything has a price
and perspective really matters and so I
think that staying in tune to what you
know when you're building an
organization somebody comes in as a 23
year old they want more money right as a
27 year old they want a little more time
because they just found the person they
think they're gonna marry then they have
a child that I mean you know then they
want money again then they want a title
because the kid that came in with is now
ahead of them 2 slots but that kid
worked 15 hours a day and didn't do
relationship and it becomes this whole
thing but you've got to keep listening
and that's what I heard from you right
now and that is HUGE listen if you're
built if you're trying to build
something listen that's where it comes
from I talk a whole lot it confuses
people I'm spending almost all my time
listening that's why I read every
[ __ ] comment that's me listening
every time you don't see me posting or
being or on live unless I'm in a
business meeting I'm reading your
comments that's how I'm figuring out
what the next piece of content is gonna
be and so that I'm just shocked and
watching so many people here want to win
and they're not replying to comments
they're not listening it's so selfish
it's a mistake and that's what every
company bossed us it's selfish and they
think much I love that you said that
they throw money at [ __ ] or dangle the
potential of money just trying to milk
you for another six months one of the
things that I've really been thinking a
lot about this year is how many times
people stop me in an airport or an event
like this or what have you and they
freak out and they're people of the
industry right especially fancier events
where there's cooler people like a lot
of people will like I'm just being like
I mean this like really like VIP events
there's inevitably like somebody like
will freak out and they'll like I never
freak out and what they're basically
saying to me is I've met way more famous
people than you and there was no
reaction why am I getting emotional or
why do I want to take this selfie with
you and it and it for and you know I'm
just and I'm like listening right so
like this is happening and happen of
course for like my ego and all that it's
awesome but I'm interested right
I'm thinking and then I'm like finally
it just made a lot of sense it's like
look you can listen I love the weekend
and future as much as anybody else but
like an artist that puts out good music
outside of like a singular song that
changed your life it's just good music
where is somebody who's putting out
content that's desperately desperately
trying for your life to be better and
wants nothing in return
you're gonna have a different reaction
when you meet that person than if
somebody can drop 54 points a night it's
just different
that long-winded humblebrag
is is positioned for one reason you need
to figure out how to bring so much value
that whatever you're trying to
accomplish just naturally happens
because you built so much leverage by
giving this is like it mad when you
don't reply to the eight people that do
leave a comment for you on your social
media you're trying to get bigger and
you don't have time for the eight people
that actually care about you right now I
mean listen you're holding it that book
the Thank You economy that's the one for
me and I say it all the time it's the
one that's sold the least and it's the
one that means the most to me because
I'm a product tonight of somebody who
from 2007 to 2011 went to sleep at 4:00
a.m. because I would not go to sleep
until every tweet directed at me got
responded to now the math is won and
I've kind of you know it's just I'm not
gonna win that game but like most of you
who have ambitions can still and you
don't and I'm really trying to put
pressure on that conversation eleven
fans become 22 if you actually give a
[ __ ] about those 11 and nobody does they
take it for granted they do a collab
with a great brand they put their name
on it they think one photo shoot and one
[ __ ] appearance at the biggest retail
store they can go to is gonna sell it
and it's just we have too many options
we have too many options and so
being positive and so how has positivity
impacted your business I mean any
entrepreneur that's successful has to
rely on positivity because it's not
rational you know like the Segway
conversation from like we're selling
sneakers here at this flea market -
we're gonna have 3,000 employees and all
these stores is not a rational one it's
it's wide students and entrepreneurs are
so different it doesn't play out on an
excel sheet and so for me positivity is
my natural DNA it's the environment my
mother created but it is an
entrepreneurial one like I remembered
something that really kind of struck me
which is the car-washing like 90 people
said no 4 said yes but it took me 30
years to remember that people said no
right and you know and so like when you
are this you're only focused on the
yeses or the positivity you don't it's a
net game the amount of mistakes you guys
have made is ludicrous
right it's just you don't think about
them when you're making progress that I
hate more than cynicism because you're
making judgment without full context so
that people that are positive versus
people that are negative are completely
exposed every day because we're making
one of the things that I'm trying to
talk a lot more about lately is judgment
we're just everyone's just in full
judgement mode because everyone's got
social and they can add their two cents
and nobody knows [ __ ] like people always
like Gary Vee why can you handle so much
criticism I'm like cuz they don't know
me they have no idea what's happening in
my bedroom and my bank account - my tax
returns and my private meetings like how
could I possibly take any weight I only
care about what people I care about what
you think about me because you know me I
care about what Colin thinks about me he
knows me right like that's what I care
about I can't care about Sally pants 63
right because because what's happening
now is we're exposing ourselves salad
pants 63 saying I suck [ __ ] that means
her life sucks if you have time to leave
negative comments on somebody else's
social media your life is not in a good
place it's the quickest tell like I have
no time to do that because my life is
good I'm busy I'm doing [ __ ] no time to
consume your video and decide you're a
dork
this ludicrous so I think what I think a
lot of people right now think that
technology is changing us and I think
it's exposing us which is why we're
going through a lot of heat right now
which is which I'm excited about it's
one step backward it's two steps forward
and I'm excited that we're finally
especially America facing a lot of its
shortcomings and I do think over a
hundred year window this this will be
looked pop back at the moment where a
lot of good happened to our society
because we had to face so many of our
truth shortcomings that we didn't want
to face and they've been hidden by
mainstream made media so it hurts a lot
of us have to deal with [ __ ] that maybe
we don't want to but I promise you watch
how they remember when you're SuperDuper
old this combo we are headed in the
right direction we're just gonna have to
deal with some [ __ ] over the next 10-15
years to reconcile the [ __ ] we've been
hiding community
Media
[Music]
you